all right 6 37 our new tuesday morning
in just a few hours if not already
fourth of july fireworks stands are
opening up all over town you know
they're run by non-profits and of one
kind or another organizations raising
money mary jane bellies is live with
more on the fireworks stands and how one
particular nonprofit is helping folks in
native a place to live good morning mary
jane
good morning to you sheri and nate well
we are talking about the freedom house
here and that fundraiser for the freedom
house kicks off this week and they're
making a big push as many local
non-profits and organizations open
fireworks stands around the valley today
the freedom house is a local non-profit
providing housing mental health
substance abuse and treatment services
for people experiencing homelessness the
freedom house hopes to raise between
seven and nine thousand dollars which
will provide two and a half years of
housing and support services for up to
fourteen people freedom house ceo jeff
iverson says all the money will go
towards their scholarship fund
this is probably like the last house on
the block for them
and
you know it's interesting a lot of
people may feel like
well they kind of got themselves into
that situation
you know they should be able to figure
it out but the bottom line is if
somebody's not there to help them with a
hand up
not necessarily a hand out like we want
to be able to provide a path for them
now you can purchase fireworks from the
freedom house in the albertson's parking
lot on the corner of rainbow and warm
springs and this is all part of the
city's safe and
safe and safe fireworks campaign which
is the only type of consumer fireworks
that you can purchase legally out here
in the city and other local cities
within the clark county area and again
everything is on sale starting now and
these fireworks really help our local
nonprofits and organizations including
the one where we're at on rainbow and
spring mountain that's benefiting the
las vegas basketball gamers so go out
there support your local non-profits and
organizations all while having fun and
safe this fourth of july reporting live
mary jane valencia live local now